[Music]
speaking today and this morning lecture
will be on codes function and high
dimension function connection between
these three objects so yesterday we
already saw that expand expander grafts
are some amazing applications towards
coding clearly we are listed these this
is exactly the slide I used yesterday
the expander graphs are used for
constructing constant rate ringing in
distance binary codes they are useful
for distance amplification and codes
they useful to get linear time unique
decodable and less decodable goods let's
look at two of these constructions and
perspective the two first two first two
applications so we have these show the
expander codes can be used towards
constructing a constant rate in your
distance binary codes and for distance
amplification now can ask the question
is this all that you can get from
expansion or can you add this can you
actually soup up this can you get these
codes with even better properties then
what's listed over here for example one
thing that you would like to ask like to
notice which is an open question there
is can we get constant rate linear
distance codes over the binary alphabet
which are also located testable testable
with a constant number of queries I will
decide I will define formally what
testable means later on on the talk but
this is an open question so do you want
to ask this
we have expanders give praise to these
sort of objects it is raised constant
rate in additional primary codes can be
further
of this object with additional property
of local testimony that's one question
we could ask patchiness
it was this other application of
expanded towards distance amplification
you to take a port with small distance
and how to fit build a port with large
distance this is the construction of
alone group now or an hour and rock and
once you have such once you come into
the world of codes with large distance
it immediately ask can you now acute
these codes actually with efficient list
decode of the log levels they have large
distance you can prove that these codes
there are some codes that are
constructed on this object do they also
have can you actually come up with FA
can be come up with efficient
algorithmic plus decodable then both
these cases both these sort of the
reason and in both these cases expansion
this is good enough to put the first few
properties but it's unclear if expansion
suffices to prove these additional
properties that we want I would like to
get these extra one and we have a sort
of vague notion that possibly if the
objects that we were using we're not
just expanders but harder had even
better properties they they were high
dimensional expanders then possibly we
could soup up these constructions and
get codes with even better properties
for example you do X Y dimension
expanders come to the rescue and aid in
either of these structures so what we
actually do know isn't the latter in the
second of the applications high damage
expanders can in fact be used to get
efficient list decodability keep the al
code with efficient leslie photograph so
the basic construction of a loan routine
or an hour and roth shows that if you
have an expander code then you can get
some distance amplification and what we
can show is if that expanded if that
expand the graph was not only it came
from a larger object which had i
dimensional expansion then not only can
you get distance amplification you can
actually it Cupid the efficient list
affordable we can come up with an
efficient list before ever the situation
in the form and the first application is
not similar we don't know but it seems
to be as if expansion is not sufficient
expansion is not sufficient to prove
local testability but if you want local
testability possibly you need something
like high dimensional function it seems
to be lurking behind in this one
so what I'll actually do is I will not
talk about the second one 420 actually
have a positive result I'll actually
spend on the entire talk on the first
one to show why possibly expansion helps
in the FIR constructing concentrate
linear distance binary codes why it
fails to achieve local testability just
near expansion fail searching local
testability and why high dimension
expansion might come to a rescue and
actually give us so this is just and I'm
sort of a wishful thinking right at this
point of time but I do feel that high
damage to expanders can play a role to
answer this question and most of the
talk is going to be ranking right why I
why I think so so I by the way I like
the latter result one of us so this is
one joint work with elite tally in ball
and I'm hoping that one of us will give
will talk about the efficiently sleep or
ability of the oven broke now now Roth
construction in one of the following
weeks
so now let's get back let's go to the
first one so just to get this one say
let's give a quick short primer on codes
and then come to the problems and so
what do and what are curves is where the
codes is we're looking at some arbitrary
subset of the boolean hypercube so they
were right now I'm looking at codes over
the zero for the boolean algebra to
point the scan all of what I see can be
generalized to larger alphabets and then
we work on codes you're interested in
two important parameters of the code the
rate and the distance of the port so
what's the rate rate is basically its
quantity defined as this quantity and
informally what it is it is exactly the
number of information bits or symbol of
the poor would this one the rate of a
code sort of and risk and then you have
the other important parameter of the
port which is the distance of a code
it's the minimum distance it's the
minimum Hamming distance between two
distinct code words between two distinct
elements of the code and typically a bit
what we'll be using
is fractional distance which is d over m
and what i would and if a code has read
if a code has is over the is a block
length n has rate R and distance Delta
this is usually denoted using this
shorthand notation that it's an N or n
Delta n to put the 2 refers to the
factors over the boolean half and what
we are what's great interest is to
construct codes with the best sort of
trade-off between rate and distance and
if this is still an open question we
don't know what is the best trade-off
between given a particular rate what's
the best distance you can get given and
so we don't know this what we do know is
we do have upper and lower ones which
not yet match and we can get pulled
towards the constant rate and linear
distance we do know is what we don't yet
know how to get the best trade-off
between these what I will be talking
most just in fact all are not just an
arbitrary code we'll be talking about
linear codes their ports in which the
set is not an arbitrary subset but it's
actually a vector space over GF 2 we are
going to view 0 that of its you know
what as the field g f2 and it's going to
be a linear space over this vector space
so once it's a linear space you can talk
about you can come up with the you can
express the code succinctly using a
generator matrix for example if it's a
linear put it's easy to show that if the
board has it if it's an nkd two-port
then that must exist the generator
matrix k by n generator matrix such that
the code is exactly specified by this
exactly images of the map XG and
similarly if this is the this is one way
this is one way of specifying the code
the other way of specifying the code is
via the parity check matrix that is if
the code is if you feel if C is an nkd
to linear port then there must exist a
parity check matrix these are basically
the constraints these are a set of
linearly independent set of constraints
which are sort of defining the port the
port is basically given by all those
elements in 0 1 to the N which satisfy
the constraint specified by the parity
check matrix
if these two in mind this would be play
important tool than what I'm going to be
saying later and for linear codes
distance of a court can be much easily
represent about as it's basically the
weight of the smallest nonzero code word
it's a smallest weight of a nonzero code
word in the port and usually when it's a
linear code I'm going to denote it using
these fire brackets and cable to just
together is a little more dirty let's
see a few examples of a few goods these
will be sort of the main characters in
the talk and I'm going to be saying so
one of the simplest of the codes is the
set of even parity strings just simple
as being a set of all n length strings
which whose parity is Z even the it's
not hard to see that this is a code in
the previous construction it's a n n
minus 1 to 4 then we have the Hatami
code which is which we talked about
yesterday this is the set of all
evaluation linear functions it's a poor
whose block length is 2 to the K here is
some parameter so block length is 2 to
the K and it basically it's all those
quotes all those strings which are the
truth table evaluation of linear
functions and linear functions is
basically a function that satisfies f of
X plus F of Y is equal f of X cos Phi
this is exactly the other model good and
it's not hard to see that the azimuth
code has its a 2k 2 to the K K 2 to the
K minus 1 code so this is for which you
talk about these are quotes over the
bully amount of it you can naturally so
so far we looked at evaluation of in-ear
functions we can begin looking at
evaluation of higher degree functions in
this case it's useful to put the larger
alphabets and the definitions Raymond
said earlier easily extend to larger
alphabets so we have these two the
famous words the reed-solomon code and
the reed-muller code the reed-solomon
code is just the evaluation of
polynomial univariate polynomials of a
particular degree and reed-muller codes
this evaluation
multivariate polynomials particularly if
these quotes in mind and then talk about
testability this one so let's go back to
code so we had a code and he sort of saw
that a linear code can always be
represented by a parity check matrix now
to be nicer for us to work with talking
more graphs in this one it makes it come
up with not with the matrix
representation of code but a graphical
representation of the poor so we talked
about the graphical representation of
the parity check matrix what do I mean
by this
given any or the parity check matrix you
can naturally associate with it the
following bipartite graphs so what's
this bipartite graph just to this
bipartite graph is just the following
graphs
so yes the parity can people see the
notebook I am right using over here yes
yes
if the parity check is this n by n minus
K matrix we view each of these as the
these are the N minus K constraints code
the natural bipartite graphs I'm going
to come about is this bipartite graph in
which this side has n elements this side
has n minus K elements and these n
elements will naturally correspond to
the n coordinates of the course and
these are going to correspond to n minus
K constraints in the parity check matrix
and suppose you have one constraint some
constraint see five is involved see five
looks like it involves Z it has ones in
the second position and say the fifth
fifth in the 8th 8th position and zeros
elsewhere the corresponding C 5 is going
to be connected to these 3 X 5 so it's
just just a graphical representation or
parity check matrix I'm saying spending
too much time for nothing for something
extremely simple over here so let's once
we have this
and this is in fact called the factor
graph of the code so given any code we
can represent it using this bipartite
graph which represents on the left-hand
side you represent the element the code
words and the right-hand side represent
the constraints and what are the clothes
what what's the code it's exactly all
those x1 to xn such that every single
constraint is satisfied that is the each
constraint at every constraint you look
at the bits that participate in that
constraint they should sum up to 0 and
this is exactly only those elements x1
to xn belong to the for so now we can
turn the question around and say so far
we we took the parity check matrix and
we constructed a graph or you can do the
other where I give you a bipartite graph
and we construct a code from this the
most natural thing you look at the code
you view the left-hand side as the
elements so you given some bipartite
graph say G equals L re the left-hand
side the right-hand side and the edges
and given any the right-hand side
naturally represents a set of
constraints that up to the code and the
code is just this is the most natural
definition actors character that is
basically I'm going to take all strings
of length L such that for every vertex
for every right-hand side vertex which I
call a constraint you have that although
you have summation excuse 0 that you
ranges over all neighbors of this vertex
P this is a natural code that comes even
a bipartite rock we can immediately
define this corresponding code to it so
given G this CG which is the foot arises
from this unlike in the previous case
the constraints in our need not be
linearly independent these constraints
in the right hand side could have
dependencies on them in which case the
constraint doesn't add any more feature
it's just going to check the same check
when we will see such codes later on you
will see codes in which the constraints
are not necessarily linearly independent
and so this is a very simple description
of a code now once I give a bipartite
graph we get a code out of this good
question to ask is how good are these
codes with respect to the two parameters
will care for with respect to rate and
distance so let's ask this question so
how good is it with respect what's the
rate of this world
so each constraint on the right hand
side reduces a dimension by at most one
hence if the number of constraints is
smaller than n then the rate is at least
n minus M by M that is each constraint
radius the dimension so that's the rate
of the foot so once we have if the
bipartite graph is up its an unbalanced
but bipartite graph with an imbalance
being that the left hand side is much
larger than the right hand side then
that immediately tells us that the
underlying core has positive rate as
positive rate so rate so far rate is
good but what about distance so if this
graph had what we seen so far at this
graph has an imbalance when the number
of constraints is far smaller than the
number of bits then we have red what
about the distance which what is there
some more properties of this graph that
will ensure distance of the of this
particular port and what we notice is if
this graph is this bipartite graph was
actually an expanding graph expanding
from the left hand side then extremely
well expanding graphs then it is then
you cannot can actually guarantee
distance and what do I mean by expanding
graph over here we talked about regular
expanders previous talks I'm going to
talk about bipartite expanders so I'll
say the graph bipartite graph l re is an
MMD Delta alpha bipartite expanded if it
has the following properties for N and M
refer to the sizes of the two sides and
if you want rate we want em to be
smaller than n I want the graph to be D
left regular regularity from the
left-hand side it should be regular from
the left-hand side and let's all that
regularity additi e and for the mode we
want log expansion from the left that is
for every subset every not to large
subset every set of size at most Delta
and the set of neighbors of this set
should be at least alpha times the size
of the set so this is what I call an NM
d delta alpha bipartite expander and
it's not hard to show that for every
epsilon that you choose between 0 and 1
and any
imbalance that you want there exists a
particular Delta and integer B such that
bipartite expanders of this these
parameters exist and you notice here the
important thing over here is we're going
to get bipartite expanders in which the
expansion factor alpha which I mentioned
above is as large as D times 1 minus
epsilon the best expansion factor one
can book for this D because that's the
degree of that's the left degree and
this says you can get as good as close
to D as you want to and how close is
depends on epsilon and simple randomized
construction sort of achieves this and
there are we mean today we know of sort
of explicit constructions which come
close to this we come to which achieve
this sort of object right now we'll just
take the fact that such objects exist
and you're sure that one such objects
exist the underlying graph the
underlying code the code that emanates
out of this bipartite graph should
actually be an experiment and that's not
hard to see if you make one simple
observation so far we are talking about
expansion you can then move on to
something called unique expansion the
expansion is refers to the set of
neighbors of a given set yes and I'm
going to further take a smaller set in
power asked what as the what are unique
neighbors unique neighbors are for
example in this graph it's drawn on the
left hand side yes and right hand side n
of s which can is the set of all
neighbors and within and of course it's
a smaller set of vertices which subset
of n effects in which each vertex over
here has a unique neighbor and s that is
all the other neighbors and NS minus us
have at least two neighbors interests
with all this the unique neighbor and
it's not hard to see that Neil asked
when is a graph just like we defined
bipartite expanders we can also define
bipartite unique expanders and this is
an easy exercise to see that if the
neighborhood of s is at least D times 1
minus epsilon s then the unique
neighborhood of s is at least D times 1
minus 2 epsilon office this is not this
is because the neighborhood you just
this is just you do a simple
double-counting argumented you get this
let me just does this clear for
everybody or should I just be clean let
me actually quickly illustrate what we
want to show that NFS is larger than or
equal to T times 1 minus epsilon times s
then this can place you of this is
larger than D times 1 minus 2 times just
a counting argument so we know that the
number of edges going out of s as e
times s this is greater than or equal to
is all the unique neighbors have exactly
one edge going out of it and all the non
unique neighbors at least two edges
going out of it so this is already 2n
minus u which says you was greater than
or equal to 2n minus es send us a times
1 minus 2
yeah so back on the slides so have this
so to say once we have such a thing once
we have so in other words let's we go
back to this so this says that in order
for this last statement to make any
sense we need epsilon to be less than
half otherwise this is a meaningless
statement over here so when it says if
we have a bipartite expander for some
epsilon being less than half so we have
an NM d delta T 1 minus epsilon
bipartite expanded some epsilon off then
it's a easy consequence of the fact that
it's a unique expander to show that the
corresponding graph has this property it
is as block length en the rate is n
minus M by n and distance Delta n we
already saw the rate Y is rate already
follows from before and distance is just
a new easy factor of this one unique
expansion implies that every non empty
set yes of Phi is less than Delta has at
least one unique label so any so any
code word which we have if it is a small
weight code word then it's at least
going to have one unique neighbor and
the corresponding constraint will be our
unsatisfied so this says that that can't
be a valid code so once you have unique
expansion you're going to have so these
are these so so once you have expanded
rafts you have these ports with constant
rate and linear distance it's quite
amazing that by pantographs give you
this so and in fact we know more about
these sort of codes that arise out of
these bipartite expanders we know that
they are actually you can efficiently
sort of unique decode them these are the
famous ipsa Spearman Munich decoding
algorithm what we want to know ask this
further can be super these expanded
rafts expanded for his grasp
can we actually add local testability to
them and we come up with these ports so
we have constructed codes which are
constant rate linear distance can we fir
also show that these same ports can also
be locally test so what is locally
testable so code C is said to be locally
testable
new locally testable if there exists a
randomized gesture that gets access to
received word w queries it or not most
queue locations and accepts or rejects W
such that whenever it sees a valid code
word it's going to accept and pin it
when it sees something which is far from
the code word it's going to reject with
the considerable properly I can't see
the audience from my end so this is what
the test ability means and what we want
to ask is so this is what testability
means and we want to construct codes
which are testable with as few queries
as possible we want to construct codes
and what does means in particular it
means it should have us you should have
codes the chat in which they do we have
lot of low weight dual constraints
because these these tests which are
checking whether the code is in the code
or not good are these key tests of size
Q and so the poor must have a lot of
dual goods particularly expander based
foods if the right degree is also small
then they will have low weight dual code
words naturally question to ask this we
construct with these amazing puts the
constant distance linear constant rate
in your distance are they also locally
testable can you acute them with local
dust ability problem can you actually
show furthermore that these expanded
codes have be constructed using just by
using bipartite expansion of unbalanced
bipartite expander graph and you also
show that they are testable testable
with the constant number of queries
a somewhat interesting uh program Luke
you just from good expansion you said we
don't know how to get to the one but can
we say anything no no so what's the
question you want to show can we put an
upper bound on how actually what will
show us for most expanders the camber
lying expander core will require meet
your number of queries to test it so
it's actually fails to be testable in a
very very strong fashion in fact yeah so
what just expansion does not get it you
in fact what we'll see what I am so in
the next few slides shortly is most
expanders in fact will most a most
random graphs which are good expanders
will have the additional property that
they actually require Omega n property
the testability will require Omega n
periods forget about constant theories
there's no it requires linear number of
queries do you realize to test the
that's what we're going to say so this
is the following you know we already saw
that if you pick a random graphs a t
left regular graph to these properties
when high probability it's a bipartite
expander and hence the underlying code
is also poured with good rate and
distance so that's the great news about
these graphs that a random graph we've
been this way has good rate and this one
but it comes with this added caveat that
with high probability the the code the
corresponding code actually requests
Omega n queries for local testability it
is strongly not testable not just
constant but Omega n to be testable so
just expansion is not going to suffice
in fact most expand across are actually
going to have this huge
require a large testability really they
fail testability in a very very strong
sense and
this is a statement of this theorem
clear so it's stating that expander
graphs are great to construct codes with
linear distance and constant rate but if
you just pick an expand a random
expander it's not going to be testable
in between so just the left D regular
would suffice but notice step to show
testability so testability is a Verity
firstly the code if it does not have any
lobate dual code words it's not testable
by a must by definition because
testability you first require lobate
dual code words so if a code has only
large weight dual code words then it's
not for example the reed-solomon code
word reed-solomon code has only large
weight dual code words you can't look
they are no short no weight to it so
that's a necessary feature for
testability which sort of says that this
graph that you construct should not only
be left regular but also from the right
it should have it should have the
constant degree 1 so that's the model
I'm going to output it will graph which
is the left regular and on most right
instructions this is their average right
degrees or their left degree right
degree is also small and that's the
model they come and with this model you
can show this following this and
actually I'll show you the proof it's
actually strongly this one under most
models most random models which you're
going to construct are going to have
this property they're going to be strong
let's say you you go for something like
configuration
with the statement the bottom statement
of the present slide remain true so
again you know coughs a random using
some variation of the configuration
level with it still be true that there
the last statement in this night so
every prefix on the network's big the
half 90s every bad the right has you
give it somehow it's free choice you
make
so we make some choices number Z we can
regularly regular and again so now you
match the half edges from the let me
tell you this what's the board happen in
the proofs this guess the following fact
so you can struck this graph you take
out you take out an any constraint from
the right-hand side
[Music]
it's easier for me to tell to be had
this bipartite is the notebook on or yes
yeah they have this bipartite cross one
and we have the code C which is defined
as constraints over get c1 c2 see em and
let's construct graphs
g-g-gee i which is basically exactly the
same graph as before it's l but r- i and
you remove the corresponding edges it
just incident on line it's this it's
just the it's the old it's the old graph
except you just remove this one
constraint off if it so happens that all
these graphs we know the g better g is a
bipartite expander if it so happens G 1
G 2 G all of GM and also bipartite
expanders which most models of
construction are actually going to give
you it is knocking of one this one is
not going to really change the expansion
of the graphs then in all those cases
you can show that the underlined C of G
this is not tested
so most any model under which this is
going to be true we're going to have
this feature and the proof basically is
just this following observation so
what's the proof two thirds as I
mentioned here so a random graph G
there's a slides back on yeah so random
graph G has the property that for every
constraint on the right if you look at
this new graph G V which is L the same
left hand side right hand side you just
knock off this one particular constraint
and Evie is just all the other edges
which are not adjacent on V this will
also be a unique expander this will also
be a unique expander with very high
probability therefore if you look at the
new code the code corresponding to this
graph CB this will also have very good
distance reboot distance in particular
this food is the super code of the code
which we are talking about the code
which is the C put as this one this has
this extra constraint the one constraint
has been removed of the code therefore
this is this is a super code of the code
that you're talking about so this is a
code with good distance of all elements
in C V which are not in C and actually
far from C all elements in C V which are
not which are not in C are far from C
because C V is a code with good distance
effort now I'm going to come up with
this hard distribution of code words
which is supported on the union of all
these CDs - C basically what we're going
to do is basically pick one of the
constraints at random on the right hand
side violate that constraint and satisfy
everything else that's the cut
distribution of code words I'm going to
just the distribution of words we are
going to come this is certainly not a
code word but from what I have said so
far all of these these all of these
words are far from the code and one can
show that actually if you go over the
construction that there is no short
there is no easy way of recognizing
because I have picked this constraint
that have been violated at random it's
one of its
elements from it's a random right
constraint it's not going to be easy to
find out if there are more short dual
constraints that this code kata spits it
what did for testability mean we need a
low weight code word you not just need a
low weight code word we need lot of low
weight code words that are violated and
this will faith failed miserably for
this object and this will basically tell
you that this this thing the codes that
come out of these objects are not
looking at the words precisely one
constraint so I'm assuming here that
become so I want to I want to mention
one other property I want that after
dropping a constraint it still remains
unique expander and all the L
constraints are actually linearly
independent constraints this will be
true if M is much smaller than n this is
always going to be the case all the M
constraints each constraint except
dropping the constraint actually changes
the code if you actually see V will be
different from CG of these so if the
randomized construction will become
construction has this property then
you're going to get this creates
basically to what this I'm not going
into the details of the proof at what
the proof is trying to understand truth
is trying to exploit it the following
fact that is if you want to show
something is locally testable we need
codes words that are far from the code
word to to startle it to violate low
weight constraints low weight
constraints that's the only ways a
tester can detect it but it can't just
violate a few low weight constraints it
has to violate a lot of low weight
constraints in order for the tester to
be able to recognize this and ports that
come out of expanders that's not going
to be the case there with very few low
weight code words that are going to be
violated by these words which are far
from the port and because of that the
any tester is going to fail to recognize
that this the failure
is going to speak to distinguish between
codes that are strings that are in the
language and things that are far in
particular this particular distribution
of borders so this exact one can go to
the details of the proof but basically
this is the construction and most of our
item models are going to have this
property and this shows why actually if
you just have expansion then it's going
to fail to be testable in a very very
strong fashion that is you going to have
you if you put these things together you
can show that actually the number of
queries required to test it is going to
be Omega n you basically have to look at
almost all the elements on the left hand
side or at least a linear fraction of
elements on the left hand side before
you find out which is the right hand
side constraint that is being violated
in which small set of problems with some
stability you need much more actually
you need that no short combination of
rows every short combination first
generates a word of of large weight
useful particularly of weight one but
this is and the blue basically
formalizing this that's why it fails so
if you build an expanded this one it's
going to fail to be testable for exactly
this reason like to ask is can i acute
the sexpanda graph it's some more
properties so I know that just if I have
expansion in this way it's not going to
be testable can only equip it with more
properties in order to make the
underlying code the code that comes out
of this bipartite graphs to be tested
that's going to be the focus what
they'll do is so the way we will go
about trying to do this we look at
examples of so we do know some codes are
no contestable for example the other
math board the reed-muller code we will
look into their proofs of testability
and show that underline in these truths
is actually the underlying bipartite
graph as some additional creatures to it
and we asked if those additional
features will help us to prove
testability in general come to that
point let's this is a good time for a
break so what we've shown so far is
codes that arise out of expanded hoods
and expanded graphs a random graph this
actually could has great properties with
respect to distance and rate but with
respect to testability it actually fails
to be testable in a very very strong
hushed precisely we had this sort of
theorem that it has good distance and
rate but the way with high probability
the code request linear number of
queries for any testicle and what we now
see is any sort of soup up this expander
with some more properties in order to
make it locally testable so to do this
we will look at existing codes which do
not necessarily have good rate and
distance but are locally testable and
see what is it that goes into proving
their local testability and see if we
can understand something or and that's
what I will do in the second part of the
top so let's break for about half an
hour or 20 minutes it will be just
around the same time 15 minute break and
we meet again for what's the time right
now I continue also but if possible but
there's a natural break there should be
good yeah